hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge mir leider ich weiß
nicht ob es kann richtig ausgesprochen
habe allerdings haben unter dem letzten
paar einerseits sehr viele leute
gemeckert weil sich richtig gespielt
habe andererseits haben sehr viele leute
gesagt ich soll es mal wieder spielen
deswegen spiele ich jetzt ja letztes ass
montag wir klicken einfach mal auf
continue ich mache hier wieder auf in
meinem tollen zimmer im sessions pärchen
her die sind hier wieder in der schule
angekommen und diesmal versuche ich mir
wirklich mal eine waffe mit zu nehmen
also ich nehme jetzt hier das nein das
heißt denn wie sie willi arndt also
natürlich dass ich irgendwie das ich
gesehen werde mit der waffe aber die
waffen liegen da einfach auf dem boden
herum
die sieht er doch auch jeder ich nehme
einfach mal die schere ich weiß nicht
ich mir bei der schere dass sich
bewaffnet bin halt weder die dicke
titten da seht ihr das die muss sich
umbringen mann ich weiß gerade echt
nicht ob man sie dass sich eine schere
in der hand habe oder ob die denken dass
ich irgendwie irgendwann wehtun würde
aber hier vor listen mit den dicken
titel da könnte ich doch theoretisch
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die das
katana schwert und laufe wirklich zu der
da hinten hin und töte die jetzt als
wenn schon wieder kaputt was sollen die
spieltag ein ganz braves mädchen und da
dies die anderen leute die hier gleich
einpacken
die wegen tatsächlich alle nicht so
begeistert aus ist einfach ein typischer
montag hier gerade oder alle hier gehen
tollen die schule rein das ist ja super
ich gucken ob ich als wenn das center
ist ich habe eigentlich in den letzten
video und anderen als mp ausgewählt aber
okay der ist natürlich auch ein harter
boy ich werde jetzt erstmal mit ihr
reden über war okay das war tatsächlich
wieder sehr gute unterhaltung tools
arbeiten wie zb das ist ein spind von
innen glaube ich also er hier vorne ist
mein crash okay ich bin in der nähe und
jetzt laufe ich hier rum um die kurve
und wo kann ich denn hier hin laufen
kann ich auch in den klassenräumen rein
hey ich weiß nicht wieso aber irgendwie
hat die kamera gerade die beiden vaginas
von denen hier an gesund also ich weiß
nicht was ich mehr bin ich mir eine
schere nehme ist das denn dann auf wie
sie blieb also erst das nicht okay das
ist nicht okay ich glaube jetzt einfach
mal hier durch mit einer schere und denk
mir jetzt okay ich habe gleich runter
man da wollte ich gerade zu der lehrerin
gehen und unterricht und jetzt jetzt
kommen wir alle an oder was o mein gott
hat die lange haare alter ich glaube
mein samples jetzt hier wieder auf der
couch genau da aber genau darauf den
brunnen und ich muss irgendwie mit dem
reden aber ich weiß nicht wie ich liebe
dich saint marie ich gebe hier zu den
mädels und rede mit denen hier blaha
komme machen wir ein bisschen gossip
hier das ist das ist super kommen dann
rede ich mir noch mal mit dir hier ok
super kompliment du bist ja super tankt
york amazing geht noch mal mit der hier
bei ok
das war eine tolle unterhaltung ist es
möglich dass sich irgendwie von den
lehrern oder so angreift hey ich mach
mal kurz die tür zu du siehst sehr
komisch aus nicht einfach mal auf talk
und mache mit ihr zäunen und jetzt schon
klappen später ich hab grad mit kleine
verwandlung hingelegt und das sehe ich
jetzt aus wien die größte mülltonne
aller zeiten hey wo ist eigentlich die
schere die ich mir vorhin mitgenommen
hatte ich habe jetzt auch noch weiter
haben schuhe an ich weiß allerdings nur
nicht wie ich jetzt diese blöde maske
endlich wieder wegschmeißen kann
davor geht dessen ruhm ich frage mich
gerade wirklich was hier vor sich geht
was kann ich nicht irgendwie doch ich
habe richtig angst wenn ich die sehe mit
diesem ritual
packen messer und ihrer komischen bresse
dar warum sache mit der niemand dass das
spiel so ekelhaft ist ich habe jetzt
einfach mal das messer abgezogen lauf
hier raus also sind hier immer noch
leute die hier ist niemand dass ein
meeting räume hier kann ich theoretisch
mal offen machen ist ja einer drin hier
ist keiner drin diesem raum hier ist
auch keine wenn ich mal hier auf dem ok
ich laufe jetzt einfach mal nach oben
und wieder nach oben und wieder nach
oben und wieder nach oben
was kann von blitz hier ist klasse 3 bis
1 ich lauf mal da rein hier ist
tatsächlich auch halo lehrerin alles was
ist das warum also mehr ultra fielen die
kommentare geschrieben dass das ganze
spiel halt so funktionieren soll dass
ich da irgendwie mit leuten reden muss
und dem typen oft also dem typen auf den
ich stehe dem sagen muss dass die leute
auf die er steht gar nicht so cool sind
und ich musste dann eben die umbringen
und bleibe das ist doch alles total
crazy
das ist doch wie gossip girl mit anime
deswegen will ich an dieser stelle auch
das video beende ich bin einfach nicht
geschaffen für dieses spiel also viele
leute amtlich im zweiten teil gewünscht
mit dem tipps und so dass ich es mache
aber ich schaffe es nicht ich bin nicht
gut in suhl anime coldplay ich muss mit
anderen reden und blau wenn ich euch
vielleicht trotzdem unterhalten konnte
freue ich mich über eine bewertung wir
sehen uns in einem anderen video wieder